[Aplausos]
[Música]
la guerra de ucrania todavía está lejos
de acabar pero desde luego ha entrado en
una nueva fase mientras rusia ha
reorganizado sus fuerzas para
intensificar su ofensiva en el este lo
cierto es que las tropas rusas se han
retirado de kiev de la capital y aún así
esta ciudad sigue siendo bombardeada y
muchos pensaréis que es todavía muy
pronto para hablar de la reconstrucción
del país es decir del día después del
fin de la guerra pero después de dos
meses de guerra es evidente que el
conflicto no se ha desarrollado tal y
como figuraba en los planes iniciales
del kremlin el ejército ruso no ha sido
capaz de controlar buena parte de
ucrania y todo indica que el oeste y el
centro del país no van a caer en manos
de putin y precisamente por este motivo
ya hay gente que está pensando en el día
después de la guerra no me creéis pues
aquí tenéis las palabras del comisario
europeo de presupuesto algo así como el
ministro de hacienda de la unión europea
johannes hahn atentos a ucrania necesita
un nuevo plan marshall tras la invasión
rusa apunta a la comisión europea
estamos ante la mayor devastación en
europa después de la segunda guerra
mundial por eso cobra sentido hablar de
lo que sería una especie de nuevo plan
marshall hablamos por supuesto de una
inversión multimillonaria pero también
de una gran oportunidad para occidente
porque atraerá al bloque de las
democracias liberales a un país como
ucrania que por cierto es el segundo
país más grande de toda europa sería
todo un gol por la escuadra en la
portería del kremlin
[Música]
un gran y además goza de suelos muy
fértiles y tiene más de 40 millones de
habitantes una población bien formada y
que no está tan envejecida dicho de otra
forma que merece la pena ayudar a
ucrania salir adelante y hacer posible
que muchos inversores privados inviertan
en este país con este vídeo te vamos a
contar cuánto costará reconstruir
ucrania por eso la pregunta que nos
hacemos es de qué cifras estamos
hablando de dónde podría salir todo ese
dinero para reconstruir ucrania qué
lecciones podemos sacar del antiguo plan
marshall hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a evitar de
cómo evitar que ataquen vuestro teléfono
móvil o vuestro ordenador porque ya lo
sabéis en internet no hay misiles pero
hay otra cosa hackers y ataques
cibernéticos y diréis cómo podemos
protegernos pues es una muy buena forma
de evitar parte de estos saqueos es
utilizando una vpn y cuál es la vpn
favorita de visual político exacto sur
shark vpn creedme el tema de la
seguridad se lo toma muy en serio por
ejemplo sur shark tiene una herramienta
que se llama clean web que bloquea todos
esos pop apps de propaganda por donde se
cuelan un montón de cookies y de bots
que francamente no queremos tener en
nuestro dispositivo por si todo esto
fuera poco con una única cuenta de surf
ser vpn podréis registrar todos los
dispositivos que queráis queréis navegar
con seguridad desde vos tras marc tv o
desde vuestro teléfono móvil o desde
vuestro ordenador pues podéis hacer todo
eso mismo con una única cuenta de surf
shark vpn y por supuesto tenemos una
oferta muy especial para todos vosotros
que seguís visual política básicamente
si utilizáis el código político
terminado en acá podéis disfrutar de 183
por ciento de descuento más tres meses
extra totalmente gratuitos tenéis los
enlaces en la descripción no esperéis
más y descargados ya la aplicación y
ahora sí vamos a ver un poco de historia
marshall
[Música]
seguramente muchos de vosotros pensaréis
que eeuu puso en marcha el plan marshall
nada más terminar la segunda guerra
mundial sin embargo mis queridos amigos
de visual polític no fue así la guerra
en europa acabó en mayo del 45 y el plan
marshall no arrancó hasta que lo aprobó
el presidente estadounidense harry
truman a comienzos de 1948 lo cierto es
que en 1945 los aliados estuvieron a
punto de cometer los mismos errores que
al final de la primera guerra mundial en
este caso el tratado de versalles impuso
entonces unas condiciones alemania tan
duras que con el tiempo propiciaron el
ascenso del nazismo al poder en eeuu
hubo un hombre que se dio cuenta de todo
esto hablamos del general george
marshall en aquel momento secretario de
estado de la administración truman
[Música]
marshall creía que la recuperación
económica de europa sería algo bueno
para eeuu la guerra había provocado un
esfuerzo industrial extraordinario pero
también había llevado al país al pleno
empleo mantenerlo en tiempos de paz era
todo un reto sus empresas necesitaban
seguir exportando ahora bien con los
países europeos completamente devastados
después de seis años de conflicto quien
iba a comprar sus productos y esa esa
era la pregunta la que marshall
respondió subvencionando su recuperación
el objetivo era que eeuu ganara un
mercado en el que vender sus productos
una política mercantilista que perseguía
evitar en la medida de lo posible que
las empresas tuvieran que despedir
trabajadores
y aquí está una de las claves el 90% del
plan marshall fueron ayudas a fondo
perdido el 'tío sam' repartía dólares
pero fundamentalmente para que se
compraran sus productos en su primer año
el 60 por ciento del plan marshall se
gastó en comida poco a poco se fue
invirtiendo más y más en maquinaria para
poder volver a poner en marcha la
industria y completar las tareas de
reconstrucción para que os hagáis una
idea se estima que un 30 por ciento de
los fondos del plan marshall se
dedicaron a materias primas y productos
semifacturados otro 30% en alimentos y
fertilizantes un 20% en maquinaria y
vehículos y un 15% en combustibles
[Música]
el plan marshall también cumplió con un
cometido político estaba perfectamente
encuadrado en la doctrina truman esta
política del presidente truman
establecía que eeuu debía brindar apoyo
económico y militar a cualquier país del
mundo para contener la expansión del
comunismo o las fuerzas soviéticas
[Música]
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando mucho
saber fonseca todos sabemos que siempre
que hay una expansión de gasto público y
de ayudas del estado se corre el riesgo
de caer en casos de corrupción o de
malas inversiones pues si tenéis razón
de hecho en washington pensaban lo mismo
y por eso crearon like a una agencia
autónoma que vigilaría el proceso antes
de soltar el dinero cada país podría
decidir cómo aprovechar los fondos del
plan marshall pero primero tendrían que
hablar con la eca que por supuesto
controlaba a eeuu
en los 4 años que se aplicó el plan
marshall en europa vivió el periodo de
máximo crecimiento económico de su
historia la producción industrial se
incrementó un 35 por ciento la
agricultura sobrepasó ampliamente en los
niveles de antes de la guerra y europa
tuvo por delante dos décadas de un
crecimiento sin precedentes que impulsó
la inversión privada ojo os lo contamos
en visual económico el plan marshall no
fue el artífice de la recuperación de
europa pero contribuyó a la estabilidad
política y económica del viejo
continente yo en un momento tan
turbulento como la guerra fría los
beneficios probablemente superaron los
costes
y ya sé lo que se está preguntando todos
en este momento va de fonseca todo esto
está muy bien pero vamos al dinero
cuánto costó la broma pues bien el plan
marshall costó 13 mil millones de
dólares 13 mil millones de dólares de la
época estamos hablando del 2% del pib
estadounidense de entonces para
reconstruir toda europa la gran cuestión
es si ahora estaríamos dispuestos a
hacer semejante esfuerzo por un país
como ucrania no podemos obviar que el
reino unido francia italia o incluso
alemania eran países con muchos lazos
con eeuu incluso en aquella época pero
en el caso de ucrania seamos honestos
estamos hablando de un país que hasta
hace cuatro días nos importaba menos que
la vida privada de will smith antes de
la gran bofetada así que la pregunta es
de verdad estamos dispuestos en
occidente a pagar la reconstrucción de
ucrania de cuántos ceros estaríamos
hablando pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Aplausos]
[Música]
factura ucraniana
vamos a decirlo claro ucrania ya era el
país más pobre de europa antes de la
guerra porque eran tan pobres pues
tenemos varios vídeos en visual político
donde lo explicamos pero si las cosas ya
estaban mal en enero de 2022 en mayo de
este mismo año están mucho peor el país
está literalmente devastado y lo cierto
es que hasta que no termine la guerra es
inútil hacer valoraciones de daños
porque estos seguirán aumentando pero
hay quien ya se atreve a hacer algunas
estimaciones atentos al presidente del
banco mundial david malpass
en europa
este cálculo es ligeramente inferior al
que indicó la escuela de economía de que
hablaba de unos 68 mil millones de
dólares
de estas cifras la mitad corresponde a
la factura que supondría restaurar las
infraestructuras dañadas
hablamos de 28 mil millones de dólares
en daño a las carreteras a eso habría
que sumarle los puentes puertos e
instalaciones ferroviarias afectadas
luego están los 20 mil millones de daños
en edificios de viviendas entre los que
directamente han sido destruidos y los
que están a punto de caerse otros daños
no alcanzan cifras tan elevadas pero
tiene mucho valor para la futura calidad
de vida de los ucranianos reconstruir
200 instalaciones de atención médica
costará otros 2 mil millones y para
reparar los centros educativos afectados
también se necesitarán unos cuantos
cientos de millones de dólares
pero esperad un momento porque tal y
como indicaba el presidente del banco
mundial estos son sólo los daños físicos
que podemos cuantificar porque según el
primer ministro de ucrania dennis smith
la factura real de la reconstrucción
será mucho más elevada ahora anda vélez
hast demons trades directamente art and
indirect closer because of the world
amount muerden five hundred sixty
visions of the doors and if it don't
stop the sword requiere de losers films
dramatic ley estas cifras serían sólo un
poco más elevadas que las aportadas por
un equipo del centro de investigación de
política económica con sede en londres
esto se ofrecerá una horquilla muy
amplia que oscila entre los 200.000 y
los 500 mil millones de dólares el plan
marshall supuso para eeuu un esfuerzo
equivalente al 2% de su pib esto
equivaldría actualmente a 450 mil
millones de dólares la pregunta es de
verdad está eeuu o la unión europea
occidente dispuesto a pagar esta factura
de verdad merece la pena ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
abu la raza
[Música]
en el año 1991 ucrania y polonia eran
dos países muy parecidos ambos acababan
de salir del comunismo ambos tenían
alrededor de 40 millones de habitantes y
ambos tenían un pib per cápita similar a
partir de ahí cualquier comparación
resulta odiosa atentos a esta gráfica
[Música]
ya lo veis ucrania solo ha conseguido
más éxitos que polonia si nos ceñimos al
festival de eurovisión y os preguntaréis
pero que han hecho en polonia que no
hayan hecho en ucrania la diferencia
está en que la polonia postcomunista el
poder quedó en manos del ex vales a que
no le tembló el pulso para desmontar el
régimen comunista y hacer una apuesta
decidida por la democracia y la
liberalización de la economía dicho de
otra forma esto es justo lo contrario
que lo que hicieron los primeros líderes
de la ucr han independiente que eran
herederos del partido comunista
soviético desde entonces las diferencias
entre ambos países fueron abismales para
que os hagáis una idea en el año 1995
polonia ya había privatizado la mayor
parte de su economía ucrania y ni
siquiera había liberalizado la
compraventa del suelo agrícola vamos que
estaban en preescolar de capitalismo
conclusión en 2004 polonia ya estaba
lista para entrar en la unión europea
los datos ahora mismo hablan por sí
solos los polacos son hoy en día tres
veces más ricos que los ucranianos la
pregunta ahora es de verdad puede lucrar
y convertirse en una nueva polonia pues
sí por supuesto que sí pero eso
significa acercarse más a europa y menos
a rusia no solo en relaciones
comerciales y políticas sino en sistema
económico
para que os hagáis una idea la
legislación laboral ucraniana se remonta
a los años 70 cuando todavía formaba
parte de la unión soviética los dos
principales bancos del país son
estatales la liberalización de la
compraventa del suelo agrícola se aprobó
hace sólo dos años y la hipercorrupción
se ha mantenido en todas las esferas del
estado hasta antes de la guerra
sin embargo ahora ha cambiado todo
porque la guerra no solo está
destruyendo las infraestructuras del
país sino que también se está llevando
por delante toda esa maraña de intereses
creados y de corrupción y hay una cosa
donde celesc y ya ha acertado de pleno y
esa es apostar lo todo por entrar en la
unión europea' vamos a ser claros si
ucrania consiguiera cumplir con todos
los requisitos para entrar en europa
significa que van en la buena dirección
pero no sólo eso también supondría una
fuente de ingresos muy importante
volvamos al caso de polonia durante sus
primeros quince años como miembros de la
unión europea polonia recibió ni más ni
menos que 160 mil millones de euros en
fondos comunitarios ahora bien como ya
hemos visto ucrania necesita mucho más
que eso antes hemos hablado de alrededor
de 500 mil millones de dólares y diréis
de dónde puede salir el resto del dinero
pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
la historia la escriben los vencedores
ucrania y ha creado un fondo para la
reconstrucción del país está
estructurado en cuatro fondos diferentes
uno enfocado a reparar las
infraestructuras destruidas otro
enfocado a atender las obligaciones
financieras del país y pagar sus deudas
el tercero está dedicado a apoyar a las
pymes para restablecer la normalidad en
el sector privado y el cuarto que está
dedicado a modernizar el país pensar que
ucrania tiene un sector y 'the muy
interesante con profesionales muy bien
formados incluso antes de la guerra de
lenski ya quería apostar por esto
atentos
queremos transformar ucrania en un país
de startups esperamos que la
participación de la tecnología en el pib
crezca del 4 al 10 por ciento para 2025
hasta los 16.500 millones de dólares lo
que nos convertirá en el hub tecnológico
más grande de europa volodomir celesc y
presidente de ucrania por supuesto que
esto es de antes de la guerra pero la
intención de lenski está clara y ucrania
tiene el talento para poder reconstruir
rápidamente su sector y además vamos a
ser claros los sueldos ucranianos pueden
ser muy competitivos para las empresas
occidentales dicho de otra manera mano
de obra barata para las startups
europeas y estadounidenses ahora bien el
estado ucraniano sigue necesitando aún
más dinero y la pregunta es quién lo va
a poner pues bien desde aquí ya lo
tienen claro
rusia si habéis oído bien rusia desde
que están presionando para hacerse con
los activos congelados al estado ruso y
a sus oligarcas en un principio esto
presenta dos problemas muy evidentes
por un lado expropiar las reservas
congeladas del banco central ruso podría
poner en tela de juicio el propio papel
del dólar como divisa de reserva mundial
si estados unidos y sus aliados pueden
expropiar la riqueza de un estado tan
fácilmente países como china o arabia
saudita entre otros muchos podrían
determinar que mantener sus reservas en
dólares no es algo nada seguro luego
respecto a la riqueza privada de los
oligarcas el problema es que los rusos
llevan años preparándose para una
situación así en contra de lo que pueda
parecer no se están incautando tantos
bienes
para que os hagáis una idea las
autoridades suizas han actuado sobre
unos 8 mil millones de dólares y diréis
hombre pues a priori esto no está mal
pero sabe a poco cuando la patronal
suiza indica que los bancos suizos
poseen más de doscientos mil millones de
dólares de riqueza rusa
[Música]
en españa por ejemplo las asociaciones
de notarias están reclamando al gobierno
nuevas medidas legales ya que consideran
que de momento no pueden actuar con los
oligarcas rusos al menos no con la
legislación actual y lo de portugal
bueno es que lo de portugal se comenta
sólo portugal sólo congelar una cuenta
rusa que sumaba 242 euros el segundo
problema es que estamos ante medidas que
violan la propiedad privada está claro
que rusia debe pagar por el daño
infringido en ucrania pero hasta qué
punto es justo que paguen por ello los
oligarcas deberían europa y eeuu violar
sus principios pues hombre que queréis
que os diga es para pensárselo porque se
está sentando un precedente que nunca se
sabe dónde puede acabar y ojo ya ocurrió
algo parecido en versalles y no sería la
primera vez que por imponer condiciones
muy duras para la paz acaba
desencadenando un conflicto aún mayor en
cualquier caso la pregunta ahora es para
vosotros creéis que europa debería
apostar por ucrania y financiar su
reconstrucción o penséis que habría que
obligar a rusia y a los oligarcas a
pagar por todos los daños que está
causando la invasión podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios y
como siempre recordad que aquí en visual
político sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribimos este canal y
darle a la campanita para no perder
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones nos
ha gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]